my grandma would not even touch it your
grandma's nice mine was like get a chunk
loud and like throw it at Joe I'm Oscar
I'm Ricardo I am II like man Teddy and
we're gonna be trying off entick Trader
Joe's Mexican food I love me some Trader
Joe's don't get me wrong but I'm just
not going down the the cultural section
for Trader Joe's like I'll get my greens
in my proteins and maybe the free cup of
coffee but I am not about to get some
authentic tamale frozen dishes at all
I've been to Trader Joe's once and it
was by accident I'm more of a gal since
pavillions type of guy cuz that's what's
gonna rebut traders is good from what I
hear like they have really good frozen
food they do from experience I am very
familiar with Trader Joe's this very
good I'm half Puerto Rican half Mexican
but uh my Mexican side is my mom's side
so I grew up having her cook for me my
grandma cooked for me and being that I'm
from Chicago now I got to go to the taco
trucks the best spots to talk to church
on my opinion uh so I make sure I get my
fix on the corners of gas stations
wherever they're serving it up yeah you
always gotta look out for like the hats
the greasy or the hands the better sort
of yeah I'm 100% Mexican so like when it
comes to real Mexican food or real
Mexican dishes we normally just cook it
at home I think Mexican food is pretty
much good and anywhere yeah I feel like
obviously Mexican food is good but
nothing beats like your grandma
Oh your dad we're not dwell on the
kitchen so I feel like as a Mexican I
feel like if we're gonna be trying a
Trader Joe's Mexican food like we know
where we kind of get ourselves until we
know it's not gonna be like traditional
like what we're used to but like I mean
I feel like I should be good
oh man the is this the illustrious
taquito
or what are we calling this here is this
Joe's version of a taco or a taquito cuz
I can't like I can't tell
these are doggy biscuits doggy biscuit
yeah thank you so much yeah yeah yeah
like hey oh yeah you throw it for the
dog and the dog goes grabs it and then
gives it back to you I'm like why are
you wasting my time
first off this tortilla is like dude I'm
just sad right now I'm like really
depressed about oh good it does it does
its job but these aren't Mexican
taquitos if that's what we were going
for the SuperDrive it's so dry I mean
the pride is in the tortilla I mean how
that is prepared and where you're
getting it from and the fact that this
was been frozen for god knows how long
it's just super dry you need something
to put it on I mean I get it hey it's
3:00 a.m. you just left the bar you see
these puppies in the freezer have at it
there's no other reason why they eat
this out in my opinion it's in
comparison there is no comparison I
don't Phil can have a trash can please
it just doesn't have any crunch so like
actual taquitos or fried turkey toes
you'll get like a nice crunch to it
this is just like the sogginess and then
the rim of the tortilla it's just like
an extra stiff piece of tortilla that it
just it doesn't work yeah I'm like
speechless I don't even know what to say
yes other than that's really funny the
thing that I think they get right is
just like the style they shred at the
the beef that might be like the closest
thing to authentic this dish gets
nothing right now I don't like first off
Jordan yeah it's like you got to make
that good and the inside is like when
you open it up it looks like solid meat
but it's like a pace maybe open it up it
looks like to know the kind of time that
subway or anything the taquitos that we
have or that we would you know get
served at home or more of a longer that
sort of look like a flute you know and
they're deep they're fried in the pan
but they're not folded like this
not even touch it your grandma's a nice
man was like get a chunk lout and like
throw it at Joe 100% if I was drunk this
would be good there you go
couple blacked out and I don't remember
what happened the night before this is
exactly what I probably ate and I won't
remember because I was blacked out this
is just not working no ass went on I
mean the wrapping itself is kind of
funny cuz like with usually when you get
tamales from home it's like covered in
like either sauce or something I don't
know I'll get first off first
impressions I love it yeah I mean I love
it but I'm scared no I'm not you're not
scared
no this looks good so far this looks
good the courthouse at some point yes
it's not acceptable in any kind of way
first of all the husk doesn't even have
any color like it looks like it hasn't
even been in the pot - like Boyle
clearly this is frozen I'm glad there's
corn husk yeah I can do that
yeah but I mean yeah you know let's
let's let's let's figure this out
oh man I like oh that's so funny they
have like a fake bird Merc like bad eggs
it looks like they Trader Joe's like let
me fool all these people buying this and
make it seem real with these burn marks
oh it's a green chile Somali so you have
your red and your green chili tamales
and sometimes indicates like pork or
chicken green normally means chicken red
normally means pork it looks like
there's like chicken and cheese maybe it
looks like they it's like they piped it
in oh they definitely did piping in it's
like yeah there's the hole where they
probably piped in this stuffy which
obviously that's not how it works
because that mine is we're supposed to
spread the masa at the top being folded
in this is clearly the hole was poked
into this point my mind
I will say it the corn part of it is
like not good and the masa is pretty bad
let's try the insights the insights not
bad but insights not bad the masa it's
not supposed to crumble in your mouth
and it's definitely crumbly
I'm done with this one I don't really
don't want to like it so everyone's very
particular about the tamales and I
thought it would be a lot worse honestly
this is really good we job Trudeau's
I'll give it to you I actually think you
got that waiver the flavor is actually
good like the cheese out of it was like
there's jalapeno in here in like chicken
and cheese which is good it's just a
massage it's just not cute whatsoever
but then sites good like I would eat the
inside if it wasn't wrapped in this
massage the ratio between masa and
filling that's pretty key and they they
got a spot on mm-hmm I would say that
you know that yeah the the masa is not
bad the loss is not well cooked well
well cooked masa
I might choose was quite surprised I
will definitely have again uh I mean if
they gave it to me I'm sure I might have
my friend I was like hungry and I was at
their house and like hey I got some
Trader Joe's tamales I'm like all right
yeah I would recommend to my friend
Skylar who probably doesn't know the
difference between tamales or whatever
Quito is well I will say this first of
all burritos are not Mexican this is an
American thing so what an educational
fact that was yeah you know if you go to
Mexico nobody like there's no such thing
as burritos it's not a thing it was
something that we created care which I
love burritos but this is it just like
just looking at it and makes my mouth
dry I want to run I mean this feels like
I have a date with my toilet and 20
minutes after I eat this you know what
first impressions first looks this kind
of reminds me of my mom's burritos well
now I feel like an [ __ ] yeah it's
like Paulino party which probably it's
what's making your mouth yeah this is
the plastic like school lunch you get on
a Wednesday I like elementary school
like this is what they
put in the ovens for you okay so there's
like a toss get some there easily recall
this castle happy more chicken I hope is
that chicken I can't even sell bone app
the teeth I'm not gonna lie this is
actually that's pretty good some of the
frozen burrito it actually might be one
of the better yeah frozen burritos I
think I've ever had yeah then you know
what's funny is like the Thornton thing
is kind of like doughy which like I like
it in this because like the filling the
consistency other goes with it but and
the flavors are actually pretty good
it's like not like I think it's a really
good version of breakfast frozen burrito
type of thing yeah like I wasn't
expecting like gotten inside that
frijoles opposed all that stuff but I
like especially more tasty than what it
looks dang Joe you're invited to the
King set that's what it is usually when
you're biting into a burrito like okay I
taste ingredients I know this was put
together I know there's a more and like
extra investment in this whereas like
with this is you could tell this is like
factory like it was probably a mush and
just squirted it in a tortilla and they
did a rap machine there's no love
there's no nobody does hands making this
and that's what I that's when we need to
put it out if I were to offer this breed
on my grandmom she would definitely toss
the chocolate right in my face
it's pretty bad but I I'm not a big fan
of most frozen burritos I mean that's
like last case scenario like you know
I'm starving to death you know what this
is this is a toll college burrito that's
what it was ranking I guess I would buy
a box of this and like bring a burrito
on the day that we don't get lunch like
I would eat this at work yeah sure this
is good like I pay days like two days
away then let me go to Trader Joe's yes
this is I'm broken I can't afford a
whole meal so I'm gonna live off of this
for the next three days it's good it's
good just thinking of us during those
hard times come on so say so my final
thoughts would be the first dish that
they keep those I I would if I'm hanging
out at the
you know I like drink a little bit too
much sauce on a Saturday night and I
just want to like nibble on stuff so I
could wake up and not be hungover I
would eat those four in that situation
the Tomales were actually not bad
I mean I would eat it as like a snack or
like a DIYer lunch sure but the burritos
no thanks overall there are elements in
there that I was like okay I would but
it wouldn't be like a go-to yeah the
only thing that I would bring into the
office and say hey guys I brought
Mexican food from Trader Joe's will
probably be the tamales like everything
else I wouldn't put that label behind it
I would just say hey these are some
frozen and taquitos and frozen burritos
I wouldn't recommend any Mexican food to
any of my family member it's coming from
Trader Joe's and that's just for safety
because I would love to sell the family
and not have them disown me I was
expecting a lot more because everyone is
always like Trader Joe's has really good
frozen food maybe the other stuff is
good which I would be open to trying but
like the Mexican dishes are not good I
mean the first dish was like as not you
I couldn't stop what it was so you
couldn't finish it I they actually have
a really good salsa they have like these
lime tortilla chips are really good and
some like spicy salsa that's
legitimately good I the only thing that
I actually do like from Trader Joe's is
they have this tub of small chocolate
chip cookies that I love to eat I can be
like a whole tub but they're like tiny
little chip cookies oh really do we have
those here